watch this sneak peek
Stanley well do you want to tell your
father about what happened at school
today um oh I flunked my math quiz no
will be other thing what other thing
what happened at school today oh this
school shooting yes school shooting oh
yeah some kid shot up the school who
shot up the school was it you no did you
get shot No
well well what's this about failing a
math quiz in just a moment we're gonna
talk about flaming hot cheetos and
Dunkin Donuts dropping the donuts but
first South Park premier are we excited
any you guys watch South Park I don't
want to sound like a shil
but it's a good show I know we worked
for Comedy Central and they are Comedy
Central so thanks boys for keeping the
lights on 22 seasons and they're so good
and they've earned the right to talk
about a school shooting yeah no one is
safe 22 years that's a most of our lives
thank you
as a fellow 22 year old any big moments
or memories from South Park over the
years as one of those shows the like we
weren't allowed to watch in my house
really good supposed to watch that and
so obviously I watch it like all the
time and I had two t-shirts in my
lifetime as a middle school student a
rough life no no he was all dead on it
so cool and then I also convinced my mom
to buy me a t-shirt of like their their
boy band called fingerbang eighth grade
I had a shirt that said finger bang on
it I didn't even know what it meant but
I was like this is cool I watched it too
and my parents because they're Russian
immigrants didn't know it was bad we
convinced him to watch it because Isaac
Hayes who was the voice of shadows
episode where he was singing about the
Saudi boss that he was under the kids
great episode
my dad's in there laughs hysterical of
him singing Oh suck on my chocolate want
to talk about this next story Joe and
put up that headline wolves and the
rapper had a run-in with some flamin hot
cheetos throw up that Instagram I just
wanna let everybody know I was in the
hospital not due to any choice but I
guess I ate too many hot cheetos okay as
I went to a hospital not because of too
many drugs but because Cheetos
I don't believe oh no I don't believe
him I think he would tell us if it was
drugs it was just like Cheetos yeah I
feel like someone without face tattoos
I'd be like no something else is up here
this guy 100% I believe he did that yeah
I think he's bragging enough that he
does drugs his name is like lil zan yeah
I bet he was snorting this hot although
people have been hospitalized for the
flamin hot cheetos before they were like
a lot like a few years ago a lot of kids
went to
like the emergency room because they
their stool is filled with what they
thought was blood but it apparently was
just Cheetos dust yeah it's full of
blood if you had to choose a drug to be
a little version of that so there's no
way it's gonna be a drug well he's a
little Sam I'm low melatonin sometimes I
need a little help I'm little agura
don't let allergies get you down big
bacteria because I get a lot of UTIs a
lot of brands today so why don't we keep
that going Julian please put up that
headline Dunkin Donuts is officially
dropping the doughnuts from the title so
you know what that means show that next
slide it's just called Dunkin I liked
what they kept the pink for the
apostrophe you wouldn't want to confuse
people exactly I tell you what I don't
care what the name is what it looks like
inside as long as I can still buy
oxycontin in the parking lot coffee sure
get a coffee when you're inside I wasn't
making a big stink about this but I grew
up in Massachusetts where I think this
is founded
I didn't look it up I think that's where
it was founded no no one says Dunkin
Donuts say go to Dunkin get some oxy
garden on the way otherwise it'll look
suspicious yeah good Boston accent yeah
have a good Boston accent it's just Mark
Wahlberg I would say this wasn't bad
Boston accent and a bad bargain
it's not like you're whispering it was
me and Jim our director we went to
Boston College
[Music]
the new stores have like these fancy
cold brew tabs
I am worried because I don't want it to
be like a fancy suave coffee place oh it
won't be they were trucker hats
I forgot that in the photo they're
pouring it into the mouth when they open
the swinging doors the back of a boxes
white box with like plastic that's my
girlfriend I go to Dunkin like pretty
much every weekend and she's a Rewards
member they got a great rewards program
that has a good rewards program because
then you understand what's going on
there you know but there are rewards
programs out there like at every
pharmacy confusing as hell what are
these points
I bought a Snickers bar when do you give
me free toothpaste just like theirs we
should just take this set away and just
put a porch
[Laughter]
no you're right ten years Wow speaking
of upvotes
comments speaking of comments the
youtube comment section speaking that is
from yesterday's episode from top Tim I
love gritty absurd dude for absurd times
you're absolutely correct it is yeah two
times a hell of a massacre
we're gonna do something different right
now
[Music]
I'm Chris cotton from every damn day and
before I became a huge Internet star I
worked a lot of odd jobs so I watched a
ton of training videos while they were
formative the storyline usually was
trash well I fixed all of that and today
I'll be training you
this is trill training
I'm an old white male can you help me
now thanks for interrupting my
conversation what first real problem can
I help you with today my girlfriend
broke my video game system last time you
said you were married I don't have time
for your judgement he'll help your
cheatin ass over there thanks for
nothing
that judgmental woman told me to tell
you about how my girlfriend broke my
gaming system why did the system look so
sticky
word to the wise melted jelly beans
leave scars and get everywhere oh you
were freaky freak you smelled dilly
beans got my hand stuck
sorry fluids were flying everywhere why
can I trust you but I can't refund this
my wife is coming home soon I need the
system back in the house ASAP I feel you
but I'm out on parole so I can't hope
Christ in heaven if my inflatable
girlfriend gave me this many problems I
would turn her into a whoopie cushion I
would fix it myself
but I obviously can't look at my glasses
I tried everything turning it on turning
it off cleaning all the lotion off the
screen if you can fix this I'll have to
thank you in the alleyway I'll fix it
but no thanks I don't have any money so
it's the alley way or the highway you're
my most successful parolee remember I'm
not just your parole officer I'm your
freedom buddy my buddies usually don't
ask me to pee in front of them but
thanks let me take a look at that game
system no problem here we go
fingers crossed it looks good to me see
putting an ex-con doesn't make you an
idiot
it does will be your job yes it does I
don't care how good a plan Sam's it's
never a good idea to rob a police state
Wow we learned a lot so get on out there
give it a go
every word donut what would you be dad
what flavor would you were donut we just
talk about what donut reply yeah he
feels like we're applying here like a
minute it was a big bonus question
jerry garcia what you guys i do it just
to clarify it's not a donut flavor right
shut up join for what i want to take
this outside my daughter sitting right
here
so check i see you
[Music]